celebrity basketball classic is
happening at the cox pavilion tomorrow
the doors open at three o'clock it's
going to be a showdown we have two of
the guys that are here uh participating
right now funky my man how you doing
buddy how are you jc i got a question
jason he is short for what jesus christ
look at you you're quick uh jorge
christopher jorge jorge christopher nice
uh-huh and andy over here how are you
doing andy good man good to see you now
you're in a guinness book world records
right i broke a world record that's
correct yeah for most signatures
tattooed on one's back these are any
signatures no these are slap searchers
it's just my ex-girlfriends mostly they
just i don't know
a long list of lovers um it's people
that have inspired me or have been part
of my childhood in uh at some point or
have just generated happiness in my life
i try to find these people and uh collab
with them can we see it no i charge for
that no of course man that's it that's
it now you guys are playing somebody's
the parlor games the big celebrity
basketball game we're going to have uh
floyd mayweather is going to be there
i'm on floyd's team
i'm i'm lucky to be on floyd's team
because i know he's really competitive
huh well gronkowski's gonna be out there
as well whose team is he on i think he's
on the opposing team i might have to
sprain my ankle
let's look at this
okay on the back here
wow
holy smokes
actually you know what yeah i brought
something for you dude i can still go oh
we gotta have that get it all right we
can add more where do you go where do
you sign them where do you sign a man's
back wherever it fits i'll go over here
now andy you guys have a so there's a
tie in a charity tie-in as well this
weekend what's going on this weekend
with everything thank you funky good
angle yeah but right there jason christ
himself you can get a tattooed uh make
it permanent or just wipe it off after
the show
there's a charity time with you guys
this weekend yeah yeah we're doing a
delivery of water around las vegas and
obviously we've got the event tomorrow
um and i think we're doing some
donations so we're going to be we're
going to be playing and racing
i think with our project we have a um
what is it a play to earn game and i
have a really good score on that game
and we're going to pitch it to like
we're going to have all the celebrities
play the game but they beat my score
we personally are going to donate a
thousand dollars for every person that
beats our score wow so i think tomorrow
could be expensive yeah yeah i'm really
bad at the games
how are you a good basketball player uh
i'd like to think so
this is gonna be it's gonna be fun
because anyone can go watch this you can
buy tickets go to costco buildings you
can go on uh celebrity sports uh
entertainment.com get your tickets five
o'clock the game starts but if i were
you i'd be there earlier because we got
a really nice attire for uh the red
carpet which starts at four so uh you
might want to check that out
quick distraction during the game
because your signatures let's say
mayweather's about to shoot you stop and
say hey sign my back and that's a good
distraction during the game but maybe
the weather is on my team so don't do
that then gronkowski yeah thank you guys
really appreciate it a lot of fun yeah
tickets for the game tomorrow go to cse
dot team and las vegas now we'll be
right back